React is built on components.
Let's learn what they are.
A component is a reusable piece of
the user interface.
It can be as small as a button,
or as large as an entire page.
In React, components are just
JavaScript functions that return markup.
Here's a button component.
It's a function called MyButton.
To use your component, reference it
like any other JSX element.
Make sure to capitalize the first letter.
That tells React it's a component.
You can use the same component
multiple times.
Nest components inside other components
to build complex user interfaces.
Components are the building blocks
of every React app.
Start with functions, and you
can build anything.
Next episode: learn about Props
to pass data to your components.